Catwoman is a familiar face – but you've
never seen her, or Zoe Kravitz, quite like
this.
"The Batman" gives audiences a brand-new version
of Gotham City where the Dark Knight has already
been operating for two years when the Riddler
rears his head to root out the corrupt officials
who take advantage of the power they have.
The film also sees Bruce Wayne struggling
with his parents' legacy when the Riddler's
mission involves secrets from his family's
past.
It seems like this new take on the Caped Crusader
will take a different approach to the classic
story than the one fans are familiar with.
Pattinson recently opened up about the role
to GQ, explaining,
"He doesn't have a playboy persona at all,
so he's kind of a weirdo as Bruce and a weirdo
as Batman, and I kept thinking there's a more
nihilistic slant to it."
Thankfully, this weirdo has a few allies on
his side to keep him on the straight and narrow
when taking on the criminals of Gotham.
One of those allies is more of a frenemy – a
mysterious cat burglar who has ties to the
mob.
Her name is Selina Kyle, aka Catwoman, and
she's brought to life this time by Zoe Kravitz.
Back in 2011, Zoë Kravitz joined the dramedy
series "Californication," which stars David
Duchovny as Hank Moody — a writer with a
penchant for drinking, drugs, and numerous
affairs — while trying to keep his daughter,
Becca, happy.
Kravitz shows up in Season 4 as Pearl, the
singer of an all-girl rock band called Queens
of Dogtown — and she invites Becca to join
the group.
Pearl and Becca get up to plenty of mischief
over the course of the series, even stealing
Hank's Porsche in one episode.
Kravitz's performance as Pearl shows she can
have a lot of fun with a role, although the
writers couldn't resist making a joke about
her famous father, Lenny Kravitz.
In the series, Pearl's dad, Ben, is dating
Hank's ex-girlfriend, Karen Van Der Beek — and
the troubled writer has a meta joke about
Ben, referring to him, derisively, as "Lenny
Kravitz."
"Speaking of dark, how's Lenny Kravitz?"
"Excuse me?"
"The Batman" may be Zoe Kravitz' biggest movie
yet, but it's not her first outing in the
superhero genre.
Her first comic book role came in 2011 when
she starred in "X-Men: First Class," Fox's
first mutant prequel.
Zoë Kravitz plays Angel Salvadore — also
known as Tempest in the comics — a mutant
with insect wings and the ability to spit
acid.
She starts out with the good guys, but things
don't stay that way, and she ends up fighting
her former friends in the movie's dramatic
ending.
It's a surprising move from Angel, who initially
seems quite happy with their mission to help
mutants.
But Kravitz's work in the role proves that
she can hold her own against other huge stars
in a big-budget comic book movie.
The star masterfully navigates Angel's moral
ambiguity, which is definitely useful when
it comes to playing Catwoman in "The Batman."
Zoë Kravitz once again proved that she can
work well in a big franchise when she joined
the Wizarding World, prominently appearing
in the second film in the "Fantastic Beasts"
series, "Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald,"
as Leta Lestrange.
Unfortunately, it doesn't seem like Leta will
return in future "Fantastic Beasts" films
since she sacrifices herself to save her fiance,
Theseus, and her old friend Newt from the
Dark wizard Gellert Grindelwald.
Then again, this is a franchise all about
magic, so it's not impossible she could return
somehow.
Zoë Kravitz also recently showed off the
true extent of her talent in HBO's buzzy drama
"Big Little Lies," playing Bonnie Carlson
opposite the likes of Reese Witherspoon, Nicole
Kidman, Shailene Woodley, and Laura Dern.
In the first season, Bonnie is in the background
of the show; she is quite happy in her marriage
with Nathan and gets on well with his daughter
Abigail.
Unfortunately, as more secrets reveal themselves
about the Monterey residents, Bonnie's life
is turned upside down.
Kravitz's performance really excels after
Season 1's shocking finale, which forces the
Monterey Five to hide more secrets from the
authorities to make sure none of them end
up going to prison.
Without getting into spoilers, the weight
of Bonnie's turmoil causes her to push her
husband away, and she even lashes out at her
mother when she comes to Monterey to help
her.
Kravitz really shows her range in "Big Little
Lies," and according to the critics, she brings
that same complexity to Selina Kyle in "The
Batman."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.